- How about this,
because next up, clams
might be an aphrodisiac.
- [Ross] Yeah.
- But apparently New York
City doesn't need one.
According to The Guardian,
noise complaints about
bedroom activity are way up.
- [Ross] Wow.
- From burrow to burrow.
(audience claps and cheers)
People are getting busy,
and being real loud about it.
Last year, there were 277 noise
complaints relating to sex.
Queens had the most, at 103.
Good for you, Queens.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, Queens.
- Manhattan had 66, Brooklyn, 55,
the Bronx 48, and Staten Island had four.
(Ross and audience laugh)
Maybe we need to send
Staten Island some clams.
- [Ross] Hey.
(Ross laughs)
- So there were some
specificities in the complaints.
I'm quoting them right now,
"She makes the bed squeak as
if it's an Olympic event".
(audience laughs)
- [Ross] Wow.
- [Drew, In A Deep Voice]
"I've slept through Earthquakes
and fires, and I couldn't
sleep through this".
- [Ross] Uh huh.
- I love this.
- I love this, too.
Let me tell you,
so we have been through
a rough couple years.
Go and get it, get yours, go for it.
(Drew laughs)
(audience claps)
And if you, I'm sorry,
If I heard this,
I would not complain, as
long as it's not too loud.
Just like, normal people,
two and a half, three minutes,
have fun doing a thing.
(Drew laughs)
Have you ever like heard people, you know,
having their kind of fun?
- Not enough.
- No, I would celebrate it.
- [Ross] Sure. I would, too.
- And then I'd become
that old lady, you know?
Who's like, I don't know,
listen, knock the boots, do
the thing, have some fun.
- Do the thing, and if you-
- Do you know how many of
my friends are pregnant
because of the pandemic?
- [Ross] Oh yeah.
- I mean, it's such a baby boom.
- It is.
- It's exciting.
Every single one of my
girlfriends is pregnant.
- Really?
- Oh my God, everyone I know.
- [Ross] Wow.
- Pregnant.
- Well, I've never like
heard people doing it, ever,
but I want to so bad.
- [Drew] For real?
- Yeah.
And if I did, I would not complain.
I would call all my best friend,
put it on speaker,
and be like, "Listen", right?
- [Drew] Totally.
- Totally.
- [Drew] I know.
- Get a life, don't complain.
- I'm sure at like three in the morning,
I'd probably be like,
"All right, you know, I gotta work".
But like, I don't think I would,
I would be happy for people.
I'd say do it up.
- Yeah. Especially speaking
to you in Staten Island,
come on.
(audience claps)
- [Drew] Let's do this.
- Step it up.
All right, finally, oh, some noodle news.
(Drew shrieks)
- That's my favorite kinda news, Rossy.
(Drew slurps)
- Yes, because we are
wrapping up our pasta week.
- [Drew] Don't say it's going away.
- [Ross] Your favorite week of all, right?
- It is.
I love a pasta, it's my
favorite food on planet Earth.
- It is.
Well, PureWow reports
TikTok's found a new way
to strain your pasta.
Yeah, turns out you've been
doing it wrong all along.
Millions have viewed this hack.
They say, you should put
your strainer into the pot,
then walk to the sink and
carefully pour out the water.
Because look, yeah, the
pasta never leaves the pot.
You understand?
'Cause all the other time
I've been like trying to hold strainer
and lift the thing, giving
myself that facial, you know,
and then lifting it out, and
I always lose a noodle or two.
What do you think?
- I feel like this one
is a "Oh, duh" moment,
like in a good way.
Like, "Oh yeah".
The only thing I would say is,
don't forget to get
the mug of pasta water,
'cause it's the magic ingredient.
- [Ross] Oh, yes.
- Which, by the way,
sometimes on that walk,
is when I remember.
(audience claps)
So like get it while it's good,
because you'll dump that out,
and then all of a sudden you'll lose that.
You can't get anything.
There's nothing you can buy,
that compares with pasta water.
So save it, but I'm gonna try this.
- Yeah, just always save, you're right.
Just a little bit of that starchy water,
'cause it will change your sauce game.
- It's the best thing,
it's the best thing you can
have in the pasta world.
(light music)